nuri is one of the most intensive
concentrations of pyramids anywhere in
the world across any culture and
civilization
[Music]
in sudan in fact there are more pyramids
than in egypt and this is a thing that
people don't think of very often
cush and egypt have a long interwoven
history
one that is just beginning to be more
fully understood
[Music]
most of what we know in the history
books about the kingdom of cush comes
from the perspective of the egyptians
because the egyptians had writing
and the egyptians wrote everything down
everything they pushed a phenomenal
amount of paper we would say in today's
world
and
we are fortunate to have a lot of those
records
but those records frame everyone outside
of egypt as somehow not equal to
or lesser than
history is written by the victors one
percent and archaeology tells the story
of the underdogs of the other 99
the best way to really verify or
disqualify a historical account is to
look for the facts on the ground
sometimes it jives with the history
books and sometimes it doesn't
archaeologist jeff emberling has
excavated many important kush monuments
uncovering its past brick by brick we
know that from the very first moment
that kush appears in in history around
2000 bc it was powerful
it was so powerful that the egyptians
at that time built a series of
fortresses along the nile to protect
themselves against the military power of
cush
from its prime position on the nile the
kush empire controlled trade routes from
the south up to egypt transporting ivory
leopard skins precious stones and gold
they had the connections with inner
africa that could bring these exotic
products all the way to egypt and to the
wider mediterranean world they were the
go-betweens and they became very very
rich and powerful off being in that
position
egypt relied on cushite gold for their
elaborate burials
and fierce cushite warriors to
supplement egyptian armies
[Music]
eventually the cushites gained so much
power the egyptians saw them as a threat
and invaded their neighbors to the south
[Music]
for the next 400 years kush was
controlled by egypt
in the beginning the egyptians imposed
their gods and temples on kush
they were taking the elites of kushite
society and giving them egyptian
education but the kushites eventually
became even more devout spiritual
followers than their conquerors
even as the egyptian empire began to
lose strength and withdraw in 1100 bc
the kushites continued building their
tombs in the shapes of pyramids
the jewelry found inside the burials
makes clear their devotion to egyptian
gods
[Music]
we know that by at least at the bare
minimum by the 8th century bc cush is on
the rise
they have thrown off the shackles of
their egyptian colonizers but they do
retain some egyptian elements
for the center of their kingdom the
cushites took over a place full of
spiritual significance to the egyptians
a stunning sandstone butte rising high
above the desert landscape
jebel barkle
or sacred mountain
[Music]
from here the cush kings were able to
control an increasingly extensive
territory
ultimately that rise of power led to the
cushites being able to conquer all of
egypt and that's historically just
remarkable
for nearly a hundred years a succession
of five cushite kings ruled all of egypt
from napita their capital they
controlled more area than any other
egyptian pharaohs
stretching from modern day cartoon to
the mediterranean
one of these cushite kings a renowned
warrior named taharka
established nuri as a royal cemetery
in many ways taharka was the most
notable 25th dynasty king
the cemetery that he established at nuri
became the royal burial ground for kush
for over 300 years so he became the
ancestor
that the succeeding kings of cush wanted
to connect themselves to
kings like nastasan
who pierce paul is hoping may still lie
inside his
i would like to find evidence of
nastasan himself
i'm not saying i want to
come up face to face with him in the
middle of the third chamber um
in the dark but
it'd be an experience
[Music]
you